let's play a game here this is a game
called owned and not owned so first
here's a viral clip when went real viral
yesterday and um once again
the left is claiming
that ben shapiro
was owned and destroyed and exposed
during a q a by uh
with a college student
and we heard about this couple weeks ago
benchmark was trending again and and uh
and the claim was that he had been owned
and destroyed and we played that clip
and it really kind of came up short
media matters hall monitor jason
campbell posted this clip and um said
this is absolutely amazing you have to
watch it in two minutes all of ben
shapiro's anti-woke tirades are just
destroyed
now like i said this one really viral
and this is the the left
seems to be the
um pretty wide agreement
that ben shapiro was totally destroyed
by this let's listen and see how that
destruction sounded
so if the idea is that
history has consequences of course
that's true that's not what you have
that is not wokeness what woken to
suggest is that fundamental institutions
in americans no it doesn't yes
i ran
i ran elizabeth warren's campaign i
helped organize her volunteers around
here
[Applause]
i am
i am a representative of workness
and that's just this is all it is well i
mean
like i mean
i
i you know i hope that when i went to go
get my first tattoo the guy had
lightning bolts and 88s tattooed on his
neck
and as a jewish person um that's really
messed up it's basically a threat there
are there are racist people who exist
the argument that you're making and i'm
going to close with this because this is
going in weird directions and i don't
really know it's not i don't know i
don't really want to know just hold up a
second this i like i let you get out
your arguments now it's time for me to
respond cause i let you say okay i'll
let you respond but no no no not but
now's my turn you
you are not characterizing what i'm
saying accurately now it's now it's my
turn your your definition is inaccurate
the reason your definition is inaccurate
is because any sentient human being
would acknowledge that history has
consequences right but if the idea is
but that's not what vocalism is vocalism
is a different thing localism suggests
that all inequalities of today are
attributable to not only historic
injustices but also continuing
injustices in the now and that all
disparities
is not just that not just conservative
is the only person not just i want to
know why why is it that
i know
i i would let that uh keep playing but
there that's it that's the whole that's
the whole clip now i know you might say
say that i'm biased and uh i kind of
have to
defend ben i don't have to now it's true
that he if he actually was totally
destroyed by a college student um
i probably wouldn't play it on the show
that is true
but then i just wouldn't play it i
wouldn't i just would not acknowledge it
at all probably
um
but i'm you know when it would be
impressive
so anytime i see one of these things
trend a college student destroys
benchmark i i always watch because i'm
like okay well let's see if he actually
does it because that would be impressive
and there's just nothing there his he
was just he destroyed ben shapiro by
pointing out
that he met a tattoo artist with an
offensive tattoo and he worked on
elizabeth warren's campaign what
first of all how are either especially
the the second thing working elizabeth
warren's campaign how is that something
to brag about in the first place i think
you actually lose the argument
from the get-go by pointing that out but
i don't even know what that's supposed
to prove exactly
there's no
there was no there was no argument
presented nothing at all
and there wasn't even an argument
presented by ben shapiro because he
didn't get a chance to speak because he
kept getting cut off
and this is this is the point
is that
the guy the kid
was able to successfully prevent ben
shapiro from making a point by
filibustering and talking over him
and on the left now that's what they
consider owning and destroying
they're not even pretending anymore that
they're going to present arguments and
defeat you
you know in the on the battlefield of
ideas that way by presenting better
ideas and defending them not even
pretending it
what they're going to do instead is just
stop you from talking
and if they can do that then you've been
obliterated
so that was supposed to be owning that
was not
here's what owning sounds like this is
democrat representative
jeffries
at a different committee hearing i want
you to just
we don't need a lot of setup here i just
want you to listen to this exchange
listen
uh mr powell letter you've
echoed a similar sentiment i think your
quote is many on the left hate justice
thomas because he is a black
conservative
who has never bowed to those who demand
that he must think a certain way because
of the color of his skin what evidence
do you have to support that
incendiary charge
when chairman benny thompson calls him
an uncle tom because of his views on
voter id and affirmative action when in
fact more black americans support voter
id and
with respect to affirmative action in
college education
they're 62 percent opposed to it so so
that is the most vile disgusting thing
you can say and and and so yes
disclaimer you're claiming my time yes
there are a lot of vile disgusting
things that can you just ask me for an
example the notion that that is right
when some members on this side of the
aisle and others have been
called the n word throughout different
points of our life belies the point that
you have a particular bias
and it's an overstatement which is not
surprising when you look at the balance
of your testimony and if chairman benny
thompson
uh has an observation to make
he's entitled to free speech you
apparently believe that jenny thomas
regardless of how many conflicts
she has is entitled to home political
opinions
uh as well
uh can i give you another example no
no you can't you can't
okay that's what
destroying somebody actually sounds like
um
that's that's what it is jeffrey says
can you give one example
this this terrible terrible charge that
people democrats have been racist
against uh justice thomas give us one
example of this okay well um here's a
guy who called him an uncle tom well uh
yeah but that's uh people have said
worse things and free speech okay i'll
give you another example no no we'll
just stop there
that's
uh it's a total humiliation you know and
that's and this is one thing i'm not a
lawyer but um
one thing i have learned just from
watching the lawyer shows
is that uh and i think it's something
you could probably take with you in in
life especially in debates is
never ask a question that you don't know
the answer to um especially in a
situation like this that's
it as a lawyer in court also in a debate
you want to pose a question to somebody
that you don't already know the answer
to it in this case
he didn't know the answer and he was
completely embarrassed i mean he's
embarrassed by any objective standard
but of course as a democrat it really
just doesn't matter at all listen hit
that subscribe button right now do it
right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated